so the other week i re-watched one of my  favorite films yes man this film follows  cole who was a bank loan officer who  starts saying yes to life and all  opportunities this also meant he started  saying yes to all the loan applications  at work leading to an increase in micro  loans  but you know what's better than micro  loans micro grants  the best of which are micro grants for  longevity  hence this leads me on to tell you about  the new micro grants on offer from  fitedale from 100 to up to 3 000  the grant can be used to get involved in  the longevity community  from funding research attending a  conference to joining a program such as  on-deck longevity fellowship on receipt  of the grant you will become a fellow to  the community so find a link in the  description if you want to apply